i've done our research and apparently
you've got these tattoos
with your
at the time boyfriends i have done that
okay so what have you learned about
permanent ink and relationships
so i am a lover i really am like i fall
hard for people and i love love i have
gotten um tattoos of ex's names with
them they've gotten the tattoos as well
and i've gotten them covered up i've
learned that a it's a curse you're not
supposed to do it it's apparently very
well known that you're not supposed to
get someone's name
um i've learned that
you don't need to do that
you don't need to do that and i've
learned not to do it it's not special
anymore
i definitely feel the impulse to do that
to express it's tattoos are how i
express myself i'm covered in tattoos
all over my body it's my form of
expression so naturally if i feel
something strongly about someone i'm
like oh my god i want to express this as
a tattoo
however
things happen and
then you gotta have a bunch of cover-ups
and boy is that annoying how many
tattoos do you have
i have
probably like 80 tattoos
how many are of x's
well they're covered up how many did you
do
i had three x's names and then one of my
exes we got each other's names five
times
five times
covered up or
i've covered them up yeah no but like
you did it once covered up did it twice
covered it no i did them five times and
then when we broke up
i covered up all five oh okay okay
what tattoo are you most proud of um i
like the dragon on my thigh and the
spider web on my knee
it's not possible to see them
okay
oh wow she's got she's got tight pants i
like the butterfly on my hand did you
just talk it did you just talk in third
person i'm thinking who's got tight
pants girls do that she tried to take
her pants off but let's just you know
pg-13 this thing what else are you
willing to show that a normal person
wouldn't be able to see that you're like
i want to show you this one okay this
was my ex's uh name and now it's a rose
got it i also like um
[Music]
um
i don't know these are my tattoos and uh
they mean a lot to me is anyone else
very intrigued by natalie and like what
she's got i think her personality
to put their name like i i admire
women i don't know we feel we feel maybe
yeah that's the thing we feel so much
it's such a beautiful [ __ ] thing to
feel so much and we full we feel the
full range we feel extreme happiness and
extreme sadness but i would always
rather take that full scale than being
somewhere in the middle moderately and
like i actually think it's really cool
even like even my logical brain that's
like okay she had to cover it up and
she's dating more people cool i wish i
could love like that five times in my
life that i was willing to you think
she's loved harder than you because she
got a tattoo of somebody
kind of you do i do
i don't know if i've been in that
question but i'm just saying like
do you think i think her capacity okay
let me know yeah did you get a tattoo of
anybody that you just kind of liked a
lot
it was full on love no if i got a tattoo
of your name like i was like [ __ ]
boom like i would leave everything for
you
that's amazing and you want that
i want it and when you find it can i say
it it can ruin your life too like it
takes away all the rationality that's
where the crazy comes in it takes away
the thing is like it's like it takes
away all your rational thought it takes
away everything it's just like i love
this person and i'm putting them above
everything
amber i wish for you
to have the type of love that you get a
[ __ ] tattoo i do i want somewhere on
your body i was just saying i feel like
all my love that's why i have no crazy
exes because my relationships have been
really pretty normal and i'm kind of
wishing for that crazy passionate
intensity i haven't had that yet manny
how many girls names do you have across
here no but as she was describing that i
got this feeling right here like oh that
sounds so draining
yeah
i want it i want it
[Music]
you